fabulous taking the picture ghost was
looking over you took the picture who
hangs a camera that far above get this
truck
excuse me I need to go talk to Elise
Levesque oh she's a teenager hey how's
it going there cherish you're obviously
not a teenager that's okay this is a
game that is a demo that is all Spokane
I don't know anything I'm tired about
Matt put on a science lecture and then
put a gig of the Sun exploding also put
in a meteor smashing into earth that'll
be good and then lightly some like dog
animals wrestling in a field mind I
can't talk and try to concentrate same
time let alone talk this game definitely
detected by happiness levels Verizon
okay exceptional realism the the drive
of the story is you're trying to escape
the stampede of elephants that are
trying to oh this is not gonna go well
do I have a bomb do I have a bomb any
sort of bomb no ok bye everybody
note yourself once you have the deed
don't ever go away from the D because
the D is obviously the best leave in my
bad
Oh Wade's gonna get it now I gotta win
but because we're in a game we can be TV
like comment favorite and subscribe if
you think Pluto's have planted it it
sure is no no good way yeah then why are
you back okay my height all my magical
spano powers come from my hand of my big
swinging ball more passion mark do you
want to RP sure I'd love to roleplay I
can be Santa Christmas doing sex yeah
thanks for watching all of the videos in
this compilation are available in the
description so check them out and if
you'd like to see more in the future
please leave a like to let me know if
you enjoyed this video and you'd like to
see more on a daily basis please
subscribe today or if you're already
subscribed share this video with a
thread thanks again for watching and
I'll see you in the next video bye bye